okay all right so this is the typical
question okay and every other question
you'll do is sort of based off the way
this works right so write out the
expansion for this now you have to sort
of be careful of this x squared right so
each term that I'm gonna have will be x
squared to the 5 and x squared to the 4
so it's going to be x squared X to the 4
XS 6 X to the 8th and the big star will
be X to the 10 okay just be careful how
you think this is wrong all right so
let's actually write it out in long form
well they do want the whole expansion
yeah so let's think back to how this
general form works okay I got taught
this first and then someone taught me
this at uni okay so my brain can't
exploded but if you find it's difficult
to wrap your head around come back to
what it means okay that it's about
arrangements but you want to you want to
actually we're solving problems this is
the fastest way sir
and she 0 what does the end correspond
to in this case it's 5 5 to 0
now what's the first term it's a to the
M now that's confusing because got a
tRNAs there but it's his first term in
the binomial okay which in this case is
x squared so I'm gonna go x squared
that's the no it's not so hard but when
you get the pattern going it's really
easy okay the next one is 5 choose 1
okay how many X Squared's do I have one
less right and then I need to bring in
one of the other guys right hey I'm
running out a route but the next one 5
choose 2 how many X Squared's are there
1 less that's 3 and how many days are
there one more that's two okay let's
finish this off 5 choose 3
5 choose 4 & 5 choose 5 one of the cool
things about doing questions like this
is that if you do it right it sort of
fixes up any errors that you might get
on its own because it's really obvious
when you look at the numbers of how they
expend okay all right yeah that's
actually do this five to zero anything
to zero right you've got a group and
you're picking none of them there's only
ever one way right which is which of
course what's the fact that this thing
is Manik yeah
so it's just X to the 10 at the front
now 5 choose 1 how many ways 5 it's like
which one okay so you it sort of clues
you into which row of Pascal's triangle
are you going to be using and eventually
you'll start to get very familiar with
the first few rows because they get used
so often now maybe you don't know this
fighters too quite as well so get your
calculator out okay
there's no shame in it because later on
it's gonna be crazy numbers like 10 15
20 okay so you're gonna need your
calculator let's say five c25 see - okay
now here's one of the cool things right
remember the 5 choose 2 and 5 choose 3
are the same right because 2 & 3 they
add up to 5 ok so therefore once you get
to this point just like in Pascal's
triangle you can just take those same
coefficients and then do a mirror match
okay so the next one is going to be 10 X
to the 4 a cubed and then back down to 5
and then lastly you've got one as you in
today okay okay now it starts to get a
little tricky and they're just little
lots of errors that creep in silly
mistakes when you start to put in extra
numbers in here okay so for instance
question two says 2x plus 3y to the
fourth okay
now I've already got the coefficients
that we need written up here okay but
you could verify them as well --shoes
not which is 1 which is 2 and so on
I'm just gonna use them unless be
careful how we do this okay I'm gonna
skip this 5 2 0 5 choose 1 5 choose 2
step because I think the number is so
low okay and also because but how we
start off first coefficient is just 1
and then you've got this guy and for
lots of them right so you're going to be
really crazy careful with your brackets
yeah
don't write to X to the 4 it's gonna be
2 X to the 4
all right next coefficient is 4 and how
many of this guy have you got one less
and how many of this guy have you got
one more okay next coefficient is 6 and
then the pattern continues now you can
see where when you're rushing in the
exam
how easy is going to be to make little
errors of these things okay
which is why you're gonna be careful
with your brackets plus 4 plus 1
okay now you're gonna have to actually
Randall this out right so 2 to the 4 is
16 2 cubed is 8 times 4 is 32 times 3 is
96
you guys have calculators so you can do
this 6 times 2 squared is 6 times 4 is
24 times 900 that's 240 minus 24
that's 216 how am i doing so far
just barely somebody okay now 4 times 2
is 8 I can bet is that 1 3 cubed is 27 8
times 27 far out okay
that's 270 minus 54 right is that 216
again okay that's convenient and then 3
to 4 is 81 tada
so these are bun dem you exhibition
right now you remember I said when
you're doing the whole expansion it's
kind of nice because going through all
the steps will sort of save you from any
errors ok but if you cost your eyes down
the sheet a little further okay
sometimes all they will ask for is well
number 1 they'll make this power crazy
go make it like 40 50 whatever okay and
then they'll say now just give me this
turn okay they'll say what's the
coefficient of this particular one or
what's the 9th term so you actually have
to go straight to here you're doing
yourself a disservice if you actually
blind out the whole thing because as you
can see number one time-consuming
number two error-prone okay so when
you've got those kinds of questions find
this term or just find the coefficient
of that term you're gonna have to get
used to using these guys okay so I think
the trickiest thing which I had trouble
with was you've got to start counting
from zero right the first term has four
entry 0 the second term is n choose 1
and so on
alright I'll take it